welcome to pj train design today we are
going to talk about this
anniversary band and how to arrange the
pattern and the stone
onto the band are you ready let's get
[Music]
started
let's take a look on this man first the
bottom part shouldn't be too much of a
problem we can just sweep
a cross section to get this one on the
top part they actually are the same
element but what is crucial is
what is the size of a stone and that's
going to fitting into this area
so we need to figure out that part so
that's starting from the scratch
so let's starting from the front view
for this ring i'm going to type in 0
here and set it up the diameter for 16
millimeter
then i'm going to do the design for my
ring i would like to have my ring is a
little bit tapered so
let's use a rectangle colony corner on
the top
i would like it to be much wider so
maybe
six or um six millimeter wide
or or a little bit less here and give it
a little bit corner there
all right and uh let's actually just
mirror that to the other side or you
want to use a rotate that is fine
so i simply just want a mirror and
snapping into the zero
move it to the bottom on the bottom
right here i would like it to be
a little bit narrower so maybe
get it close to three and a half so then
we have
um everything here it's going to use a
line vertical
command and type it zero so they will
align perfectly there
to making into a ring we can use the
sweep one rail
you go the rail and you go cross section
here and here just need to make sure the
arrow is aligned
in this case it's inside of a ring shank
and they are facing the same direction
right so you only get half of it it's
because you're telling the rhino go from
this cross section to this cross section
and all we need to do is a closed sweep
and tell it right now you go back to the
first
cross section and then we hit okay then
we'll get this ring here
all right the second thing is we need to
figure out
how is that s shape is working there
so let me hiding this uh ring here so
it's not bothering us
and what i like to do is create a curve
coming here
and going like this more like an s shape
here
so we are going to turn on the gray snap
and we gonna snap in here
coming over
here and then here and then coming over
here so we create this beautiful shape
here
let's bring in the stone and let's place
the stone
right here next to it uh you can make
the stone whatever size you want it
um but what we wanted to do
is put place a stone here and moving
this
part next to it something like this i
leave a little
a bit disturb this because i wanted to
because i want to make sure that
the prong has the room to go so what i
need to do is
actually having this two point and kind
of
curve up adjusted something like this
and maybe i wanted to curve and maybe i
wanted to curve in a little bit more
so it's talking to the other side
and of course after change it it might
be slightly different there
and we are going to do the same thing
this one
if i have another one about right there
and this one is going to moving and
talking and this one will go up a little
bit
something like this all right and let's
do
one more test bring this one
here coming over here
and see if that's talking nicely
and you want to actually like them to be
uh overlapping so that way
you can make sure that when you're
boiling union um
that will be together all right so this
one may be moving
a little bit more and i would like to uh
use the command curve from two view
and i want to select this one and this
one all right
we don't need the one on the bottom this
one is what we need
and and i would like to mark them in the
red color
okay so this is the curve that we need
let me go ahead to
hiding this one and hiding this one
okay so now we wanted to do is to
creating the cross section so let me
using the
conic corner again and i want to snap in
to the quadrant and depends on how fat
you like
for each of the element and how tall you
would like it to have
here so maybe that is one and for this
one let's
move it from the
center or the midpoint to the quadrant
right there
and i also like it to be
a line towards the direction you know
on the rail and then i'm going to making
a copy right here
moving like this
and move like this okay and of course i
want him to be a little bit shorter
like that and i also want it to coming
down like this
and you might want to get a little bit
lower so you can trim them off
uh nice and flush on the bottom
all right so we got that one and i also
have the same one
it's going to make a copy over here
like this all right so we can do a test
we might need to have a little bit more
angle
over there but let's do a test we want
to do the sweep to
a sweep one rail you got rail cross
cross
cross and then you get something like
this
um we can simply just cap that because
supposedly they will be
talking together right so now what i
like to do is i want to select
uh both of the curve and the object that
we made
and look like i make it a little bit too
fast so i need to move this out a little
bit
and then uh let's pick up the curve in
the object that we made
and that's using the rotate min we want
to snapping into the zero
and let's rotate it somewhere like
eyeball it something like this
okay so double make sure that look nice
and we can kind of arrange the stone
now for the stone i actually like to
make it as a full prong so i'm gonna
draw a prong approximately about this
tall
and then simply just pipe it
so this one is going to pipe is
somewhere about this size
and um this type of setting is uh in my
video a lot so i'm not gonna repeating
the criteria for making this one but uh
if you're interesting about more about
stone setting you can check out my
course at the description below and then
we simply just want a polar array so
let's go to
array polar and we want to snapping into
the
vertex and let's use the number for fall
and get something like this okay and um
i also wanted to create a cylinder which
is
under stone bezel i'm sorry a
tube and we wanted the tube to go
maybe
maybe from here to here
or something like that okay so now we
have this tube
oops a little bit too tall and we want
to bring down
something like this and that will be our
first set
uh i don't want to i don't want to
bullying them yet
because i might need to changing
something there but i would like to
group them so i can move them all
together
now in this case i like to have the
prong in this orientation
and then i wanted to have another one
there so i'm gonna move it
somewhere like here and making a cup in
fact
i might need to have this one just a
little bit smaller
okay so something like this
and another one gonna go
like this here all right so and we're
gonna look at the side view
now all three of them are the same
height but if you have this one sitting
in there
this one gonna come in lower and
it's actually stick it out in this way
like that so in fact we might need to
tilt it just a little bit
there to look nicer
um i do not like the gap is that much
there
so maybe i wanted to use a shared prong
instead
let's ungroup this one and we want to
did it this
one and did it this one let's go ahead
to move
all of this coming in a little bit more
and then instead of a two prong here i
might just need to have
one prong over there and did it this one
so you look cleaner
there maybe i need to uh
adjust the prong to move it more close
to
the other side to make it a little bit
more balanced okay
so then that is working fine and instead
of
redoing this one maybe all i need to do
is pick up this guy
and then we simply want to group them
and mirror to the other side
snapping into the zero coming over here
and we just need to
move it to the place i want to ungroup
this one
moving this prong coming over here
and moving this two coming down a little
bit
so that would be a shared prong i think
this look much nicer
all right so if everything look good to
you let's go ahead to
group this one okay so i'm going to
hiding all of this we just did on the
top let's hide it and
this is what i wanted to show you we do
have
a point in between like here and here
there's a distance there
so what i like to do is simply to
measure that distance so first things i
wanted to do
is draw a straight line and snapping
into the intersection of
this guy right here and let's connect it
to
the zero and that's our first line the
second
line is intersection and connected to
the zero as well
all right so that gives us a two line at
the front view and then we know that if
we go into the dimension tool and we can
measure
this one to this one and that is a 17.1
degree
all right so what we need to do is
making every
other uh element it's rotated the same
degree so let's bring back
for what we have there and hiding this
ring again
and then so what the the element we are
going to
move is those two and i'm going to
making a copy by rotate this is the
center
this is the first point so make sure
your near is
on and then i want to making a copy by
just snapping into
you know another or you can just type it
the degree that you found there
simply what we wanted to do is
make sure copy equal yes so you got one
there all right
so the next things we wanted to do is
keep making the copy if you want a three
section
and you can making a copy one more time
from here to there
so if you like everything let's go ahead
to select
everybody and we want to use a rotating
tool
this time we want to rotate it from the
top view
and go 180 degree so we'll get something
like this
after that let's turn on the ring that
we have
so for this ring i would like to them to
to actually uh having a better
transition that this one may be a little
bit too tall
so i'm going to delete this one and
coming back
with my curve so i want to invert a
selection
and hiding all of them so we can just
now dealing with this guy so let's go
ahead to
1d scale to make this one snapping into
the quadrant snapping quadrant here and
quadrant here and just bring down a
little bit
we don't need a lot of them right so
let's turn it back to the rest of the
things
so sweep one rail one more time this is
your rail and and your cross section is
here
this curve and this curve okay
um then you want to close the sweep it's
time you need to make sure that
it is lower over there so we can have a
better trim there
okay so now let's click ok
and we need to get rid of the things in
the middle
that doesn't look good and blocking all
the light for our stone so that's using
bowling
split and this guy is going to be
split by this one
and this one so then you will have this
and everything else
in the middle you can delete it click on
this one and did it
rest of it it made have another piece
right in the middle
this one you want to did it you don't
want any extra piece
it may cause problem for the printing so
we want to pick up this one and did it
this
all right so this will be the
anniversary paint
for our tutorial today if you are a
beginner for
jewelry care design i have an online
course on my website you are more than
welcome to check out the curriculum
i hope you enjoy the video leave the
comment below let me know what you
think thank you for watching i'll see
you next
[Music]
you